die dritte welle rollt an symbolhafter
geht es kaum
45.000 fans verwandeln wembley in eine
partymeile im nationalstadion gegen
deutschland der höchste fußball feiertag
von spiel zu spiel steigt die zahl der
zulässigen zuschauer während ebenso
rasant im ganzen land die zahl der
neuinfektionen steigt
ungehemmt feiern trotz hoch ansteckender
delta variante gefährlich vor allem für
jüngere noch nicht zweifach geimpft
geologen sehen hier ein super special
event fans die lang ersehnte überfällige
freiheit
wir müssen mit dem virus leben
irgendwann kommt der punkt um zu sagen
genug ist genug
es gibt schlimmere killer wie krebs für
mich ist ganz klar nun ist die zeit
gekommen indem man uns erlauben muss mit
dem virus statt in ständiger angst zu
leben des corona es ist vorbei lasst uns
weitermachen fußball heißt leben
also ich war auch erst gab mich
natürlich aber wir mussten ja alle einen
negativen test jetzt mitbringen und von
da an glaube ich dass das einigermaßen
gut geregelt ist ja der nachweis eine
selbstauskunft man habe einen test
gemacht der mann negativ was nicht
überprüfbar ist
deutliche zahlen eine warnung für
wembley besucher präsentiert die
schottische gesundheitsbehörde 1500
schottische fans die zum vorrundenspiel
gegen england gereist waren haben sich
mit delta infiziert dazu dürften noch
viel mehr unerkannte fälle kommen bei
einem spiel mit halb so vielen
zuschauern die gegen deutschland
fussball
als treiber der infektion und der
ungerechtigkeit so sieht das richard
morris zehn tage zwangs hotel quarantäne
liegen hinter ihm
nach sechs monaten montage auf den
philippinen
unglaublich schlechtes essen
unfreundliches personal kleine räume
kein platz für sport ganz furchtbar
nach der rückkehr aus manila begrüßt in
die heimat mit einem hotelaufenthalt für
satte 2000 euro der freiberufliche
flugzeugmechaniker fand wegen corona zu
hause keinen job mehr wollte keine
staatliche stütze unbedingt arbeiten in
einem schmuddeligen mini hotelzimmer
hocken sei er nun behandelt worden die
ein verbrecher 20 minuten freigang
täglich das essen hätte nicht mal
gefängnis qualität
doch der kragen geplatzt als er aus den
nachrichten von der sonderbehandlung für
könig fußball erfuhr dass 2000 uefa
offiziellen und wie apps erlaubt wird
ohne quarantäne durchs land zu reisen
ist ein starkes stück
die eigenen bürger werden in hotels
gezwungen
ich finde das verrückt und das heißt das
wurde möglich gemacht weil die uefa
gedroht hatte wembley die spiele weg zu
nehmen
der schmusekurs mit dem fußballverband
ist auch beim protestzug der
klubbesitzer und konzertveranstalter das
thema am sonntag ging es durch die
londoner innenstadt zum amtssitz von
premier sonst macht die klubs wieder auf
boris du bist ein langweiler fordert sie
etwa seit 15 monaten ist feiern verboten
party gut im wahrsten sinn
es ist auch nicht fair dass 60.000 in
ein stadion dürfen zigtausende zum
pferderennen in ascot aber wir dürfen
uns nicht mit 1000 leuten auf einer
wiese die seele aus dem leib tanzen
mittendrin einer der organisatoren
atwood carney
seine konzertagentur mit sitz in brüssel
london und ibiza betreut künstler aus
ganz britannien bis jetzt erzählt er
kann er seine firma gerade noch über
wasser halten so geht das nicht weiter
ein zweiter sommer ohne veranstaltung
überleben wir nicht die doppelmoral geht
er wird mächtig gegen den strich fußball
tennis formel 1 da geht alles per
ausnahmegenehmigung aber die clubszene
sowie veranstalter hätten keine lobby
die branche steht vor dem ruin nachdem
das versprochene ende der korona
beschränkungen mehrmals verschoben die
live musik industrie hat test
veranstaltungen durchgeführt und beide
massen events sind gut gegangen haben
bewiesen dass musik veranstaltung sicher
sein können
wir wollen endlich ein verbindliches
datum wann wir hier in großbritannien
wieder loslegen können
doch die test veranstaltungen liefen
bevor die delta variante sich
ausbreitete und der protest überzeugt
nicht wirklich als werbung für corona
sicheres feiern ebenso wenig überzeugend
der zick zack kurs der regierung
die infektionszahlen gehen steil nach
oben 26.000 fälle täglich die inzidenz
steigt von 20 auf fast 160 trotzdem
immer mehr ausnahmen für
massenveranstaltungen die begründung aus
dem amtssitz des premiers schon zwei
drittel der erwachsenen seien komplett
geimpft was hohen schutz gegen schwere
verläufe und todesfälle biete aber die
del tabelle waren virologen bauer sich
erst auf es geht nicht nur um die
jüngeren von denen wir wissen dass sie
deutlich weniger unter einer infektion
leiden aber durch sie erreicht das virus
die gefährdeten menschen und jüngst
veröffentlichte studien zeigen dass
selbst jüngere die kaum oder keine
symptome hatten trotzdem an longo wird
erkranken können etwas sehr lange
anhalten und quälend sein kann
das ist ein grund zur sorge es geht
nicht darum menschen den spaß zu
verderben sondern nur zu sagen denkt mal
darüber nach und zeit vorsichtig
mahnende stimmen die im siegestaumel der
englischen fans eher stören
der preis dafür könnte ein rückschlag im
kampf gegen korona sein oben drauf haben
regierung und eva beschlossen noch mehr
zuschauer bei den halbfinals und im
finale zuzulassen
65.000 der fußball bringt menschen
zusammen heißt es
im triumph gefühl auf dem weg nach hause
stellt sich wohl kaum einer die frage ob
das in einer pandemie wirklich eine gute
idee ist